what I want to do in this video is talk
a little bit about compounding
compounding interest and then have a
little bit of a discussion of a way to
quickly a kind of an approximate way to
figure out how quickly something
compounds and then we'll actually see
how good of an approximation this really
is so just as a review let's say I'm
running some type of a bank and I tell
you that I am offering 10 percent
interest that compounds annually
compounds compounds annually that's
usually not the case in a real bank you
would probably compound continuously but
I'm just going to keep it a simple
example compounding annually there are
other videos on compounding continuously
this makes the math a little simpler and
all that means is that let's say today
today you deposit $100 in that bank
account if we wait one year and you just
keep that in the bank account then
you'll have your hundred dollars you'll
have your hundred dollars plus 10% on
your hundred dollar deposit 10% of a
hundred is going to be another ten
dollars so after a year you're going to
have one hundred and ten dollars one
hundred and ten dollars you can just say
I added ten percent to the hundred and
then after two years or a year after
that first year after two years you're
going to get ten percent not just on the
hundred dollars you're going to get ten
percent on the hundred and ten dollars
so your 10% on 110 is you're going to
get another eleven dollars so 10 percent
110 is $11 so you're gonna get 110 that
was you can imagine your deposit
entering your second year and then you
get plus ten percent on that not ten
percent on your initial deposit that's
why we say it compounds you get interest
on the interest from previous years so
110 plus now eleven dollars so every
year the amount of interest we're
getting if we don't read draw anything
goes up so now we have a hundred and one
hundred and twenty one dollars and I
could just keep
that and the general way to figure out
how much you have after let's say n
years is you multiply it so let's say
some let's say my original I'll use a
little bit of algebra here so let's say
this is my original deposit or my
principal however you want to view it
after X years so after one year you
would just multiply it to get to get to
this number right here you multiply it
by one point one one actually let me do
it this way I don't want to be too
abstract so just to get the math here so
to get to this number right here we just
multiplied that number right there is a
hundred times one plus ten percent or
you could say one point one now this
number right here is going to be this
one hundred ten times one point one
again so it's this it's the hundred
times one point one which was this
number right there and now we're going
to multiply that times one point one
again and remember where does the one
point one come from 1.1 1.1 is the same
thing as one hundred percent plus
another 10 percent right that's what
we're getting we have a hundred percent
of our original deposit plus another 10
percent so we're multiplying by one
point one here we're doing that twice we
multiply by one point one twice so after
three years how much money do we have
it's going to be so after three years
we're going to have 100 times one point
one to the one point one to the third
power after n years now we're getting a
little abstract here we're going to have
a 100 times one point one to the nth
power and now you could imagine this is
not easy to calculate and if we this was
a this was all the situation where we're
dealing with 10% if we were dealing in a
world would say let's say it's 7% so
let's say this is a different reality
here where we have 7% compounding annual
interest then after one year one year we
would have 100 times instead of one
point one it'd be a hundred percent plus
7% or 1.07 after let's skip let's go
two three years after three years I
could do two in between it'd be 100
times 1.07 to the third power 1.0 seven
times itself three times after n years
would be 1.07 to the nth power so I
think you get the sense here that
although the idea is reasonably simple
to actually calculate compounding
interest is actually pretty difficult
and even more let's say I were to ask
you how long does it take how long does
it take to double your money so if you
were to just use this math right here
you'd have to say gee I would have to
double my money I would have to start
with $100 and I'm going to multiply that
times let's say whatever let's say it's
a 10% interest 1 point 1 or 1 point 10
and depending on how you want to view it
to the X is equal to well I'm gonna
double my money so it's gonna have to
equal to $200 and I'm now I'm going to
have to solve for X and I'm gonna have
to do some logarithms here you can
divide both sides by 100 you get 1 point
1 to the X is equal to 2 I just divided
both sides by a hundred and then you
could take the logarithm of both sides
base 1.1 and you get X and I'm showing
you that this is complicated on purpose
and any of this is confusing there's
multiple videos on how to solve these
you get X is equal to log base 1.1 of 2
and most of us cannot do this in our
head so although the idea is simple how
long will it take for me to double my
money to actually solve it to get the
exact answer is not an easy thing to do
you can just keep if you have a simple
calculator you can kind of keep
incrementing the number of years until
you get a number that's close but no
straightforward way to do it and this is
what 10% if we're doing it with 9.3% it
just becomes even even more difficult so
what I'm gonna do in the next video is
I'm gonna explain something called the
rule of 72 which is an approximate way
to figure out how long to answer this
question how long does it take to double
your I forgot the word right the most
important word how long does it take to
double your money
and we'll see how good of an
approximation it is in that next video
[Music]